This exact lead scraping system makes me
over $100,000 a month consistently and
has helped hundreds of entrepreneurs get
their very first five clients and
businesses to scale. Most free lead
guides that you see are either outdated,
expensive, or frankly just don't work.
But after spending years building lead
generation systems for my own business
and for clients, I'm going to show you
the full system that you can follow that
will get you high quality leads without
paying for super expensive APIs. I'm
going to show you how you automate the
process of getting leads, taking you
from beginner to expert. There'll be
timestamps down below this video, so
feel free to jump around as you like.
And as always, I'm going to put the
blueprints down below description so you
can build along with me in real time.
So, welcome to the world's most
comprehensive master class on lead
generation on YouTube. Now, the goal of
this is to take you from beginner to
expert. So, you can build really cool
lead generation systems that actually
work. Now, I'm going to show you eight
lead generation systems in this video
and they've generated millions of
dollars. For example, in my AI agency,
Teddy AI, we've helped clients do it. I
built it in my own businesses. These are
extremely effective. But I can give you
nothing without a reality check. My
purpose of making this video is to help
you build systems that get you leads
reliably and work. But if I don't give
you these brutal truths, none of what I
talk about in this video is going to
work. If you're not getting clients or
you're not getting as many clients as
you are now, and you're feeling
frustrated that you're not getting the
clients that you think you deserve, it
is not the fault of the market. It is
your offer or your execution. Something
is wrong in one of those two things. And
this is great news because what we talk
about is extreme ownership and owning
the fact that you're not getting leads
because something has gone wrong further
upstream. Now, here's a question for you
and this is really important context to
understand. How many people do you think
buy your thing after the first contact,
the first email, the first DM, the first
outreach, the first phone call? What
percentage of sales do you think that
is? I'll give you a second to think
about it. Only 2%. Only 2% ever buy on
the first contact. And this is really
poor. I'm going to bust some some truths
here that's going to drastically
increase the number of leads that you
get. And one out of two give up on their
first contact. They literally stop him.
And this is your competition, which is
great news. Now, one out of 10 10% the
top 8% who make over five contacts win
the majority of deals. I really want you
to sink in with this because I can give
you the best lead generation systems on
the planet. But if you don't understand
this concept, it's never going to turn
to clients for you. Literally, the top 8
to 10% are having all of the deals
because they're doing all of the
follow-up. Now, none of these Epic
systems work if you do nothing. Well,
this guy can do nothing. It's a
beautiful, beautiful Sash. We Well,
we're happy with him doing nothing. The
profit is in the follow-up. This is the
only thing you ever take from this
video. This was an extremely worthwhile
video for you. The profit exists in the
follow-up. And what we're not going to
do here is spray and pray and hope for
the best and send generic emails out to
people. I'm going to show you actual
systematized things that you can do with
proven data that will actually work. And
since you're in the top 10%, I'm going
to show you how to to stop leads feeling
like it's some kind of magic to get them
with a repeatable system. and for full
transparency on the cost for every
single automation system that I show you
in this video so that you're not
overpaying. I'm also going to show you
how you turn those leads once you get
them into a profitable funnel cuz once
we got the leads, next thing we need to
do is turn them into actual clients. In
1848, we had the gigantic California
gold rush. Thousands of people went down
there to try and dig gold, but only a
few ever actually found the gold. The
ones that did knew exactly where to dig.
Now in this analogy, the pickaxe is our
lead generation system. It's the thing
that gets us leads. But knowing where to
dig is your niche. Now niche is so
powerful. And I can't talk about giving
you the most beautiful ever like pickaxe
if we don't talk about exactly what it
is that we need to do and where we need
to dig. I can give you any kind of
leads, but are there the right leads
that you want? So very simply put, there
are three aspects that we care about
when it comes to leads. And this is the
things that I think about when I think
about my niche. The first one is we're
looking for somebody with a painoint.
Specifically, does the niche have a
massive quantifiable financial pain? In
other words, the problem that you're
solving when we're trying to figure out,
okay, we're getting leads, but who do we
want? We want that person to have a
quantifiable financial pain. Because if
I say, hey, Jack, this is costing you
$15,000 a month and it's only going to
cost you 5K to fix it. That's an obvious
yes. Now, think about it like this. if
they lose 30k a month without you a 5k
per month return it makes perfect sense
but the problem is a lot of people
target leads that just aren't valuable
that's number one the second thing that
we want is this which is purchasing
power as this guy in a beautiful pink
Ferrari swimming in money actually
perfectly explains the idea with this is
that does the target decision maker have
the authority and the ability to spend
$10,000 a month so we need to ask these
questions because when we're doing these
lead generation scraping systems we're
going to be specific about who it is
didn't want to speak and so we may not
want to get the junior executives's
assistant's best friend because they're
not really in a position they can
actually make calls decisions. So we
will target different parts of the
organization of course but ideally we
want to find someone who actually has
capacity to make the purchase decisions
and finally presence. These are the
three Ps and the presence is that can we
actually find over a thousand contacts
that fit this bill. So for example,
targeting small business owners is
difficult. But targeting heads of market
marketing B2B SAS companies with this
number of employees is a lot easier.
Okay, beautiful. Now we talk about here
which is the big and beautiful ICP also
known as ideal client profile. And the
analogy I want to throw this at is that
like the ICP is the scope. The ICP says,
"I know that I could get any kind of
leads, but the knowing who we're trying
to target is like the scope on a sniper
rifle, and the job of this video is to
give you a big, beautiful sniper rifle
that you can target our beautiful ICP
with, right? And all we're talking about
here is the scope." And as you can see,
my beautiful circle drawing skills are
right there. So, that's what we're
talking about when we're talking about
ICP. Ideally, when we know who the ICP
is, we can draw a big and beautiful X on
the map cuz we know exactly the kind of
individual and business that we're
targeting. Now, if you're somebody who
hasn't gotten their first five clients
yet, I discuss this at length in the
community. We have systems and process
to show you exactly how you go from zero
to getting your first five clients
nailed down and locked down. But the
thing I really want you to understand if
you don't know this yet and what it's
going to be really important for you to
understand to actually turn these
clients into customers is writing down
their with a big capsule P problem
statements. We need to understand what
are the things that cause them pain and
we need to have a list of those things
so we can really understand what are the
things they dislike and what are the
things that they're moving towards that
they actually want and even though it's
outside the scope of this video I just
want to briefly give you two quick
things you can do if you haven't started
yet. One is what we call the high
leverage pain which is finding that 10k
per month at least headache that we're
solving for the client and then having a
measurable highv value problem and
secondly the fit in can your system
eliminate that problem. But the final
point I want to make, and it's going to
be so valuable as a foundation for this
video, is what I call the compass. Now,
the idea with the ICP, and you'll find
this when you're getting leads, is that
think of it more as a theory rather than
a set in stone thing. And what we do is
we refine our ICP as we go. We start off
with I think they're this, and then we
take, you know, say for example that you
and I are on the beach together, okay?
And we're we're mining for gold, right?
We we follow the beeps. So, we make an
educated guess. I think the beeps are
here and we go there and did the beeps
increase? No. Okay, cool. Then we need
to go check over here. So, it's not
something set in stone. It's something
we have a theory about. We think that
these kinds of people, we test the leads
and if we got a rock slide offer like
I've shown in this video and it isn't
resonating, then we just pivot the ICP.
But really, really important to
understand. And now we've covered those
important things on niches. I'm going to
show you eight get my fingers out lead
generation systems that are going to
crush it. If you haven't already guys,
grab that coffee. This is going to be
really fun. So, I'm going to show you
how to get clients. I'm going to show
you how to scrape leads. I'm going to
show you how to enrich the data so you
can actually contact them. I'm going to
show you how you create personalized
emails. Also, how you can create bespoke
LinkedIn messages for that client based
on their profile. And I'm also going to
show you how to get people coming to
you. Now, there's a lot of information
out there that's not been said, and I'm
going to kind of pull back the curtain
and show you some really interesting
things here. But first, there are two
parts to this. One is scraping, which is
probably one of the reasons why you
clicked on this video. And the second is
organic. Remember, my objective here is
simple. I want to make you getting
clients as simple and as easy as
possible. And I have to explain the full
picture, otherwise I'm not doing my job
properly. Now, we're going to call these
our two systems. System one is scraping,
and system two is organic. Now, lots of
people start with scraping. They start
with trying to go out and find leads
using the platforms and systems that I'm
about to show you, but they end up in
organic to really take it to 7 8 9
figures plus to to get into crazy
territory. Now, scraping, think of it
like this. Our system one is to automate
high volume targeted lead generation for
free or essentially free, low cost.
Whereas organic is a self-reinforcing
system that compounds over time and
replaces the daily grind with scalable
leverage. This is the thing that we
want. If I said, "Which of these two
things would you like?" Most people
would like the replacing daily grind
with scalable leverage, right? Which is
why I'm going to include it in this
video and show you the systems that I've
used personally to generate millions of
dollars. I'm going to cover both as this
beautiful smiley face does. And I'm also
going to show you as well how 82% of
people get their first three to five
clients once I've shown you those two
things because this is really important
information. Now this is the lead
scraper that I'm going to show you how
it works basically. So effectively what
this does is we grab leads from a
scraper on Apify. Now what's really
important about this is that everybody
was using a basically technology called
Apollo on Apify. Now if you're not
familiar is like Willie Monk's emporium
of beautiful scrapers. You can
effectively scrape anything you want to
with the software here. Now, what
happened was there was a a scraper
called Apollo, which is connected to a
really good lead enrichment database.
They basically stopped working. So,
everyone's like, "What the hell do we do
now?" I'm going to show you what we do
now. But effectively, the way this works
is we select a scraper that goes off and
scrapes information. And this comes back
to our no code platform, which if you're
not familiar is, I'm sure many of you
will be at this point, NAN, which just
basically lets us connect things to
other things. I flew to New York. I
competed in their first ever AI agent
competition. It was very very cool. Um
really cool platform. So what's
happening? We are getting data from a
scraper online and this is going to be
pretty much the 80% of all you ever do
on these things. And we call this a
request. Now what we do in this request
is we request the data and we also get
the data back at the same time in one
simple module which is really cool and
again I'm going to pull this down below
in the description for you so you can
just upload this and try it. Then we
have this AI agent that does some really
interesting things. So crucially, it
does three very very key bits of data
for us. So we get leads and I'm going to
show you what this looks like right now.
So I click on this and this is an
example of leads that we got. So I just
basically said, look, I want you to
scrape people in this. I I'll show you
the variables in a second, but it's
really important that you understand
what the flow looks like so you're
equipped with the knowledge. Now look,
we get first name guys, last name,
email, their full name, their job title,
the company name, the website, the
industry. All of this incredible
information comes through based on stuff
the description of the company. We even
get their LinkedIn profile. That's how
crazy that is. And once we set what
those parameters are that are important
to us that represent our ideal client
profile, we then just go forward and get
all these different outputs. Now, that's
really cool. So, what does that look
like in practice? Well, we kind of just
take the data from that and I've pinned
it in N10 just so we can go through
this. And now we have this beautiful AI
agent that does a couple of interesting
things. So what we do to the agent is we
give it some really interesting
information. We say look this is the
name of the person basically this is
their company name executive leaders elm
uh which I've seen a couple of times now
their website their the country which
they're in the LinkedIn profile which
will just be specific right here. I'll
add this one down here. LinkedIn
profile. Beautiful. And then a
description what the company does. So
this AI now knows everything about I say
everything but it knows who this
individual is. Now crucially once we've
got the data we could if we wanted to
just email it but actually what we kind
of want to do is do some research so we
can get what I would call personalized
information so that we can end up with a
database the looks something like this
where we have the company the website
the name the the surname first name
surname the email the title now this is
really interesting I'm going to show you
how you can actually create a unique
LinkedIn request we've got the industry
all this key thing and then guys you
know what's really interesting here is
I've the AI is actually going I'm going
to do research and pull back five key
factoids about that individual, right?
How and also where it got the
information from so you can feel
confident when you're using this
information your email campaigns. And
I've just pulled up this email
sequencing cheat sheet as an example
here. Like when you've got these custom
things say, "Hey, first name, I noticed
that your company recently had this
interesting thing. We help similar
company achieve XYZ metric XYZ days."
And you have this really cool This
sequence here, by the way, is proven to
get some pretty incredible results. In
fact, I believe it's an expected 15 to
25% reply rate across the five emails
that it sends. It's really, really,
really good. When, like I told you
earlier, the reply rate to everything.
So, you can basically now customize
these beautiful fivestep sequences and
the second they reply, they then go into
warm leads and then we nurture them
properly. But the idea is that we've
collected these unique uh facts about
them, right? So, what they do and recent
awards that they've won and all this
kind of stuff. Now, the AI what it's
doing here is basically scraping the
LinkedIn profile. So, it's going to the
LinkedIn profile and finding information
about their bio, what un you know, what
do they study at? Um, what jobs have
they held, what kind of things are they
are they talking about? So, we get that
data. We also go over to the website and
we just download the information. We're
doing this via a HTTP request where
basically has get and company website
which we just mapped from this really
simply. We just map it over and then it
downloads everything which is really
freaking cool and we get that in JSON
which is nice. And then we also have
Tabi. Now what Tavi is going to do is
effectively go on the internet and
ruthlessly research the individuals for
it. So I even show you here for example
you can even see like it just goes to
different responses. It will go back and
have a look. You can see the kind of
things it's googling and as you can see
guys it does interesting things like
look query is K awards promotion
speaking events publications
achievements anything you can get back
like that that's really interesting that
will be relevant to them and it shows
you and does that. So with LinkedIn
we're doing their website and also
searching the internet which is pretty
cool. And then we have these two models.
I would recommend that you use chat GBT.
Well, you can use either, but when it's
creating copy, we like Claude. And when
it's doing other things, I just like
using Chat GBT. It's a personal
preference. I just find that Claude
writes in a more natural way that
resonates with me. So, this agent is
doing the research on those three
things. Now, once that has happened, we
have got a second agent that is going to
create a subject and a oneliner for us.
Now what's interesting here is this
concept of probabilism and determinism
which is a really key thing to
understand. You need to get this in AI.
Probabilism is where we say to AI, hey I
want you to write an email based on all
this information and you ask it 10 times
you get 10 completely different emails.
Determinism is that it the the outputs
are very determined. So in other words
that the email sequence say for example
this one is always the same with one
core exception we may change um the
first name that is hardcoded in that's
the email's always going to read hi
first name right and it's going to be I
noticed and the company is always going
to be the company but then this thing
here which is specific trigger event is
going to be very different based on the
research so the concept here is that we
throttle these outputs so that only a
certain Part of it is probabilistic
because as you know AI is a basically
next token prediction machine. So it
just kind of that's why for example if I
said the cat in the 90% of the time you
guess is going to say hat but some of
the time it's going to say a different
answer. So the idea here is that we give
it these little snippets to fill in. So
the AI is actually going to create this.
Now what's really interesting here is
the fact that the AIS like I always say
are 200 IQ interns. And what we want to
do is have one out this one very
specific thing. So the only thing this
guy does, the only thing it does is
create a subject and a oneliner. That's
it. Okay. So for example, this is the um
subject line which is quick question
about Executive Network's upcoming
finance summit. Why is it saying that?
It's saying that because in our lead
system over here, the subject line for
email one is quick question about
company's specific trigger event. The
prompt for this one is really cool which
is quick question about the companies
network finance. Okay, beautiful. Now
this is really cool. Okay, so you got to
think about now we have this is mass
personalization or scale guys. It is
crazy and this is the full system for
it. I notice that companies recently
insert specific trigger event. So this
is the reason we include this just FYI
as it looks like you've actually done
some kind of research and kind of
personalization. It's interesting. Okay.
Now I noticed that in certain companies
recently hosted a 500 um person CPO
summit in London. Like you imagine that
you just did a meet up. So for example
in my community for instance we do
meetups in all over the world like
Dubai, London, Germany. Uh you know you
pretty much name it. We did a meet up
there. Imagine if I got an email saying
hey Jack saw you just did a meet up in
Dubai. Really freaking cool. Like no
one's really saying that level
personalization but we've got that
because we've got the website and the
LinkedIn data. Really cool. So this is
what this guy does is gives us now
personalization. And the idea with this
is that we would build out simply five
of these really simply. This is cool. We
copy this guy. And this is the kind of
thing that we're building for clients,
guys. Clients really freaking love this
because it just prints and it's just
super freaking effective. So look, I
come down here and then this would be
subject and oneliner
two. Okay. And then what we do here is
just do the next one. And you can just
literally start creating all of these
things sequentially. Okay, so let's come
back here. So we've got this information
and again I've just included one email
just so I can show it you in a way that
makes perfect sense and then you get it.
But the idea here then is we've got all
the data. Now we just create and
backfill all the information um that
basically falls in our stuff. And I put
down here a list of the things that
you're going to want to get which is
going to be triggering event,
interesting fact, interesting fact,
interesting fact, personal detail, uh
specific pain point related to the role.
So what this is like with your um ICP,
do you know how I told you that you need
to get a list of pain points? So the
idea here for example would be something
like um you know one of the pain points
I help in my education business is you
know if you're feeling frustrated that
you don't have as many clients as you
want to right and if you even though
you're you're working really hard and
you're trying AI that's a pain point
that I've solved and I help people do
that loads of people do that so that
would be one of the pain points I would
talk about in my education business
right and then you're similar company so
this would be an example of here are
like 20 people that like were exactly
like you that now have all these
beautiful clients and they didn't know
what they're doing initially and now
we're doing XYZ. So I can say, "Hey, we
just helped so and so or from looking at
a business point of view, we just helped
another medical company build a rag
system that accomplishes this exact same
thing." So it's about credibility and
proof. Proof is proof kills. Honestly,
proof is crazy. And then you got
specific metric and your results. So
your actual results, remember specific
numbers are better than anything else.
And then you've got different facts and
what you think their project and goal
are. your email campaigns are going to
be way more effective the more specific
you can be and the more that you
understand who you're talking to which
is why I wanted to include that thing on
there ICP because I'm not doing my job
properly if I don't now we've got that
then crucially interestingly is LinkedIn
oneliner so growing on LinkedIn and
we're going to touch on LinkedIn lead
generation later in the video very
excited sharing cool stuff with you that
I'm learning on that uh with the systems
that we're building is we want to create
a bespoke onlineer right I've even hit
my mic that's how fired up I'm getting
and there's lots really interesting
things and I have to draw your attention
to this because this is really really
interesting data. Right, let me just
come over to my community and show you
this. So, I went really deep on what is
actually working with LinkedIn and I
found some very interesting facts and
this was kind of what I was doing when I
was recording this video for you. So,
you can get 78% acceptance rates with
LinkedIn and it is you can only send 20
requests per day. I'm going to show you
the full strategy in a second, right?
But there's loads of stuff that I've
just baked into this system for you
here. So, you just take the system. It's
just all there for you. But there's
loads of things about you do and you
don't do, right? About pre-warming up,
about your connection request. You want
to be specific, show genuine interest,
explain why you keep it short, you sound
human. What you don't do is vo generic
blah blah blah. And there's load of
templates you can use examples that
work. All this sort of stuff, right? So,
the idea is that we've built all this
stuff into LinkedIn tester. And what it
does is based on again all the
information LinkedIn profile, we'll
create that for you. And then all we
fixed after that is we just add them all
just to the database. and then you're
ready to go for the campaign generation.
Start kicking some butt, which is kind
of pretty cool news, guys, isn't it? So,
let me show you um briefly on Ampify how
it works. So, effectively what we do is
we would look over here. I'm going to go
over to my actors real quick. And you're
looking for leads finder. Okay. Now, the
price of this is $1.50
for 1,000 leads. It's an alternative to
Apollo. Now, as they've had to pivot
quite quickly, sometimes it doesn't
always give me the results exactly as
I'd want to. They're working on those
bugs actively. So, this won't be 100%
perfect 100% of the time. I'll be really
transparent about that with you. It is
the best alternative that I found. When
Apollo changed their information data
points, basically all the kind of
scrapers that running Apollo stop
working. So, this is like the best pivot
that I've seen recently. And as it
changes, I will give you the best most
recent one that I actually find that
will work for you. So, effectively, what
we do is we specify things like number
of leads to fetch, job titles. Um,
again, you can be specific. I found job
titles guys to be honest with you not
that helpful personally and that's just
because everyone calls themselves
everything like I think technically um I
don't know what my title was but like it
was something completely random that
would never ever appear in this stuff
you can pick the specificity so the
countries and the cities if you're going
to do local stuff you include location
to exclude email status I definitely
recommend you have validated company
website um size uh 21 to50 I've got down
here industries you can be specific on
that keywords revenue all this Beautiful
stuff. Now, when this is done, you're
going to click on the JSTO. So,
basically go down this and again, I'll
put a link down below for Appify. I
believe they give you like 30% off or
something with my link. So, I'll I'll
put that down below for you. And you
have a number of leads to fetch. I'd
recommend that you start with a slightly
smaller batch initially. Although
really, guys, $150 for a,000 leads um is
really really freaking cool. I think I
scripted like 30,000 leads this week. It
was crazy. But the point here is that um
we want to start with a certain amount.
you're going to specify everything. But
on a JSON, like if I change this, for
example, if I job title, if I just say
something like, I don't know, CEO, I add
that in. Do you see how now I click on
to JSON that this is changed to CEO jobs
co. So basically just specify that as
much as you want to. And then what I
want to do is copy this. And by the way,
you'll see the blueprint. What you
effectively do with these things, guys,
is you click on these dots, you click on
import from file, you select the thing,
and then the entire thing will populate
for you. So, just so you know, like and
that's how you sort of get access to all
the the blueprints. Now, once you've
done that, you're going to come over
here, click on this guy. You are then
going to come over here to the token
here, which uh my editor, my chief
blurring officer has kindly kind of
blended out for us. But basically, what
you're going to come down here is this
JSON section, and you see I've got this
information. Just a delete, then enter
in your code. Okay, that's going to be
specific for you. You know, you don't
need to come and do this in any 10 if
you don't want to, but one of the
reasons I like doing this here is
because then I can add all the follow-up
things to it without having to
manipulate the data. So, it just makes
it easier. And obviously, you can add in
forms and things at the front if you
want to. So, we do that. Then, we need
to get your API key. So, just for um
those who may not know where it is, you
come down here to Appy. Actually, you
come down to settings, you come over to
API and integrations, and just click the
copy button. That's basically it. And
then you come back over to your
scenario. And then where it says value,
you just paste in there. And once you've
done that, it's ready to work. And then
we've got AI agent. So I've kept to mine
to track GPT include. If you've never
connected it to OpenAI before, just go
on to um platform. In fact, let me show
you right now just so you've got it.
Platform.opa.com. Once again, come down
here on the left hand side. I need to
sign into this one, but effectively
you'll see a button for API key. Just
copy it in the exact same way. Same
thing with Claude, but I'll put a link
down below for you there. And then
basically we've got the whole system.
And just to show you the prompt real
quick, we can come down here. You can
see it all effectively plays very
nicely. Your sales intelligence
researcher filled with personalized
information research step. You can use
Tavly, you can do the XYZ, and then I've
got the outputs. Now, here's a really
important part of this is that what I'm
with the outputs here is I have
specified within output parser what I
want. So, I want fact one, explanation
one, fact two, explanation two. So, I
want the unique point and then I also
want the research. So you could go one
step further if you wanted to which is
to have a second AI to validate which is
is this true? You know you can really
get on in depth with this sort of stuff.
So look, Levi To is currently the growth
manager at FlipX a software company in
the UK that provides Alexaike voice AI.
Cool. He found Le on LinkedIn's profile.
Okay, that's from his LinkedIn. Let's
have a look what else we've got.
Interesting things. So there you go.
They announced the seesat and revenue
analytics in January 24 as per
Crunchbased news. Beautiful. And you got
all these different things. voice
automation launch for healthcare. There
you go. Okay. Flip X is backed by top
investors including Amazon Alexa, blah
blah blah. Very, very, very, very cool.
And then we just go through and it just
populates everything for us
automatically in a Google sheet. And
just from that, guys, you'll have
everything you need to using this
particular scrape, which means you can
get thousands of leads just following
that system step by step. And just to
show you an example of this, I've got
the subject oneliner. So, I'm going to
hit play on this with the data we've
already got and we've pinned everything
before. And by the way, if you're brand
new to any tent, you never built
anything before, you can watch this
video up on screen where I show you the
complete basics of building this whole
stuff out step by step. So look, it's
basically creating out a subject and a
oneliner. So I can click on this guy and
have a quick look. Quick question about
exactly what's upcoming CFO summit. I
noticed you hosted a large CFO summit in
London. Very, very cool. So let's pin
this one here real quick. And then what
we're going to do is bring this guy over
and have a little chat. So let's give
the LinkedIn oneliner a thing to see now
based on all this information what would
it do with that. So let's come down here
have a quick look and then beyond that
guys we have the LinkedIn oneliner. Now
again this is using the LinkedIn scraper
on ampify. So just to show you what that
is very quick you come over to appi
store and you just type in LinkedIn once
again and then we should see the
LinkedIn scraper. It's a job scraper
post scraper. Again, we can like script
the posts and just get all that key
information if you want to or just go
for the home profile. Post will give you
a lot more significance and more detail
about stuff they've actually said,
especially if you want to connect, but
come over to the beautiful scenario
which I have right here and click on
play. You can get a good example how
this will work. So, we've got our model,
our backup model here. It's now scraping
their LinkedIn and will give us a
oneliner message that we can send. Now,
what's really cool here and that I want
you to do in LinkedIn is I want you to
give it context about who you are. So,
just give this LinkedIn oneliner um AI
agent here specifics on your background,
your university, things that you do. Cuz
what this LinkedIn agent will do, guys,
is actually go through your background.
Like, hey, uh Todd, I saw that you also
studied law at the University of
Sheffield. Like, if someone said, "Hey,
Jack, you studied law at University of
Sheffield as well." I'd be like, "Dude,
yeah. Okay, so cool." So, it's trying to
find commonalities. It's got like seven
or eight different commonality filters
that it's using. So, just give it
information about you like like a page
worth of data. You can even just copy it
from your LinkedIn profile. And you can
see it has some interesting thing there,
right? And just give us different
options that we can use based on
information and then it just all updates
to Google sheets. Let me just show what
that looks like. And if I just play
this, you'll see the data being added
down here like bap bop as we go through.
Just give that a hot second and then we
should see it filter. And then this will
just keep on working all the way through
your entire libase. So you've got a big
and beautiful libra script for
effectively $0. Now number two is the
beautiful Google maps. So, if you're a
business that has a need to speak to
people in a local and specific
geography, you're going to you want to
book yourself in for this one cuz it is
crazy. Let me show you what I mean. So,
this scenario we're using, now there's
two ways you can do this. You can do
this with ampify and without ampify
because we can't actually just enter a
specific search term that will for
example, if I go on to Google maps real
quick and I say, hey, barbers and leads,
which is search term I used to I mean,
my barber and leads is amazing. I highly
recommend where is ambassador Barb I'm
getting down rabbit hole but the point
is you if we were selling if we were a
leadsbased manufacturer of clippers this
information is really important for us
right so I but I don't want to clip
stand here click it for 15 hours I just
want to scrape it which is why this is
perfect for those kinds of scenarios or
businesses that you're servicing now
what's interesting here and I did this
in testing with you guys and I always
want to be super honest about what isn't
working that's just the way that I am
about it when I had a HTTP scoper that
was going on Google Maps. I just found
that it wasn't really getting anywhere
near the quality of the data for various
different reasons. So, what I've opted
for instead I found a little bit more
reliable was just the Google map scraper
from Ampify realistically. PS, by the
way, in my first tech startup that I
sold, physical mail is a very, very
uncongested channel. Like we were
selling to developers at one point and I
sent a brick to every top developer in
the UK to the head office and I was it
was some kind of funny joke like um I
forgot what it was at the time but we
had like 15% response rate to that and
it was only like a couple hundred pounds
or something. It was really really cool
if you want to go for like big wells and
stuff. It was very effective. So you
come on the Google map scrap uh maps
scraper and again you got loads of
different things you can do here but
effectively what we're doing is we are
uh grabbing the information. Now, I've
got a form here to make it easy, just to
show you what that looks like. If I cl
here, what you're going to do when this
runs is you can have a search term. Now,
what you need to do with this search
term, again, this blueprint is also down
below for you, is enter in a plus in
between the words. So, for example, if I
wanted leads plus
uh where we are now, Barbers,
and how many results I want? Let's say I
want 20 and I submit. Now, once that
data is completed, we get all of the
data here in the edit field section.
Right? So again we got the query and
we've also got the string which is cool.
So and then what this will do is
basically go forward and scrape that
information. So here for example this
has pulled down dental dental clinics
and leads as one that I just ran
earlier. You can see we've got all of
the key information which is very very
nice. What we effectively do here is
extract some of the data. So I've gotten
so much data but it's just very
unorganized and unstructured. So what we
do is we have this code node and it'll
extract the only five things that I
really care about which is going to be
the name of practice, the address, the
phone number, the website and then a
summary of everything that they do. And
that's basically the code. If you're
ever struggling, you can just say chat
lord make me code that does this thing
that straightforward. Okay, so this is
what the code I've got. And by the way
you would do that is you'd feed it the
inputs. Then we have this system here
which is called so the loop exists
because we need to add a weight node
into it. So you see this HTTP request.
If you blast something too much, what
starts happening here is it will start
to fail when you're doing this at scale.
So we have their website and we just
scrape the data from the website. Um we
then have this thing here which is going
to extract uh text. So basically instead
of HTML we get text. We wait a second
and we do this all the way over until
it's all complete. And then it comes
through to this beautiful AI agent which
is very very cool. And this agent once
again is going to go ahead and do some
interesting things for us which is
basically give us five facts based on
that information. For example, they are
a fivestar local rate dental practice.
They offer free consultations. They
provide in um invisal line clear
retainers starting from 2K blah blah
blah. So we've got some interesting
information and again you just configure
this as you wish and then we just update
it to the Google map section here which
is cool. And we got our five facts. So
obviously just add in the where did you
get the information from and what we
would do is just then superpower this
guy with all of the researching
firepower that we had from our last
automation. Right? So all you would
simply do is come down and grab this
information here so we can get all of
the data and bring it off uh paste it
in. So you can make this research guy as
powerful as you would physically like to
do all the stuff for us. Then it just
gets added into this Google sheet. But
the next question mark is Jack this is
cool but how do I now get their email
address? Well, the service that I found
really helpful, guys, is this one, which
is anyfinder.com.
So, uh, we're going to head over there
right now and find some cool stuff. So,
I'm over here. Um, I'll put again, I'll
put a link for all this sort of stuff
down below. So, within any mailfinder,
what we do is we come on left hand side
to bulk search. You get 50 credits
completely for free, by the way. And
click on upload the list. So, you'd come
over, you download your list real quick.
So, we come down, let's just download
this as a uh CSV real quick. Beautiful.
And then we're going to head over to
bulk search and then update list. And so
we're going to come down here for
company search. Just click on this guy.
And then we just upload the data
basically. Beautiful. So it's pulled
through all of the data. So then we'll
just go through process. We don't need
to give it a name per se. And then it's
working. And what this want to do for us
is go and extract and grab emails. Now
here's the thing. You can do this
technically for free, but if I'm being
just brutally transparent with you guys,
this is your business at the end of the
day, right? You want it to be making you
tens of thousands of profit every single
month. And there are certain things
where you've just got to invest a little
bit of money to get a return. Like think
about it. Like if you take my last
startup for example, I there I was
putting in I when I was doing my I was
doing I was doing my like comfy strategy
job basically and I was investing money
into that business every single month. I
think it was in like in the initial
stages it's like500 to,000 every single
month with no return for 10 months. Then
it broke even then it replaced my income
and then it made 10K and then and then
then all the way up until I I sold it
and that sort of stuff. So, it's good.
Now, we're talking here about dollars,
right? We're not talking about $1,000.
We're talking about dollars. So, I just
said this to say that like it's good to
avoid costs, but being realistic, you're
trading off on time, quality, and money.
So, there is a value to your time. And
what I'm saying here is like when you're
thinking about completely zero cost
stuff, like you sat in front of Google
copy and pasting emails, sometimes
paying like I'm not saying go and buy
any mailer per se. I'm just saying like
just generally speaking as a principle
just think about your time when you're
doing this stuff cuz you you know you
could reinvest that time in actually
selling and growing your business. So I
look at preview let's see how it's done
and guys look at this. So now it's given
us the actual email addresses which I
think is really freaking cool. So I just
say hey we'll download those 10 emails.
That sounds fantastic. Yeah we'll have
the CSVs and just like that we've now
actually created emails for us like
this. Bam. And we got it. And now we've
got this all these different emails
which is amazing. And what's really cool
with this guys is we can actually bulb
this into any tent. We're going to be
showing you how you do that inside the
community in a master class. I didn't
want to make this far too complicated,
but effectively that's how you can
scrape. And now you've got literally
anything. And then anytime that you want
to get more information like say, okay,
so I've done leads dentists, but why
don't I just do Manchester
Smiths? I don't know how many man Smiths
are, and I I want a 100 of them. Yeah.
Then all you do, guys, is just this. And
then the whole system works on
autopilot. getting you incredible leads.
And to give you the specifics on pricing
for this one, it is $4 per 1,000 leads,
but as a business, it's two bucks 20.
I'm not 100% sure on the business gold
discount. I don't know if that's like a
plan that AppFi has, but effectively
you're paying like 4 cents per lead,
which is great. So, if you have a
product that makes like anywhere above
like a couple of dollars, it shouldn't
be too difficult to get a great ROI on
that. So number three is a free
alternative to this, but it requires a
little bit more work. But on top of
that, you can also scrape any data from
any website effectively free. So we're
going to Google and we're going to find
a plugin called Instant Data Scraper.
Beautiful. And I'm going to come down
all these guys. You can tell it's big if
the guys are trying to crush it. So we
go over to the Chrome store and let's
install this bad boy. We're going to add
this one to Brave. 4.9 with 6 and 12K
ratings. It's not so bad, right? Cool.
So we've got this stuff here, which is
decent. All right, cool. It's added in
and it's almost like a Pokeball. So,
what I always like to do with my Chrome
extensions is basically make sure that
they are pinned. So, let's come down and
details and we're going to add this one
to the toolbar. Beautiful. All right.
Now, let's head over and do this
together. So, let's do the same thing
again. Leads barbers. Okay. Now, if I
come over to maps, here's what's really
cool. So, let's say I want to scrape all
these leads barbers as if for instance.
Okay. loads and loads and loads and
loads and loads. And this doesn't just
work for Google Maps. It works for any
website possible. Look, I come over, I
click on this guy, it's going to open up
full screen. And just like that, it has
literally bought in all of these things
instantaneously, which is crazy. And
that is just absolutely freaking wild.
And you can see they've got everything
there. Friendly staff, um, reviews,
opening times, everything that you want.
And it's sort of done instantaneously,
which I think is absolutely crazy. Now
guys, I'm going to show you something
else that is going to blow your mind and
this is a really cool trick. So come
over to Google and basically you can
type in site, for example,
instagram.com. Then you enter in your
keyword with in quotation marks and then
you're going to add in different
alternatives for emails. I've just added
three in here, gmail.com or yahoo.com or
outlook.com.
Check this out. I hit enter. Now look at
this. What this is going to do is pull
every single um user on Instagram that h
cuz it's all indexed on Google now that
is a barber. So has barber in their bio
which we expect barbers to have and has
it in. So look there's his email address
there's his email address. There's and
just like that we've gotten all these
emails completely for free which is not
too bad right? So what do we do then?
We're going to click on our email
scraper guy. I'm going to um full screen
this guy and let's just bring over here.
I might need to Okay, just kind of
unfull screen him a little bit. Let's
have a look. And let's bring up our
email finder guy, which is over here, I
think. Okay, cool. So, click on locate
next button. So, I'm looking for this.
Let's just bring him up quick. So, what
we want to do is click on try. I think
this is fine. That's the right table.
So, we can actually see if it's pulled
through the emails.
I think it has got the data. So you can
actually physically go through and check
like there's an Instagram bio, there's a
data, there you go, there's the actual
emails which are included there, but you
can actually click on try another table
if that's not what you want. So that is
the one that we want, right? So
basically keep going through until you
find the one you want. Now click on
locate next button and you're going to
come down and click on next. Just like
that. Then if you come over to and just
bring it back up again real quick. There
you go. Once that's done, start
crawling. Bam. And now this is just
going to go through every page. grab
everything, keep doing everything it
needs to. Now, if I just click on stop
crawling for a second. Let's just see
what we got. Okay, so what's happened
here is I didn't use the right one,
which is really good, actually, because
now we can just retry again. I can show
you again properly. So, let me just make
sure it's all deleted. Cool. Uh, we
click on this guy.
Fantastic. Now, we wanted to find the
right data. So, it's find the table.
It's this one. Cool. And then click on
locate next button. Come down to the
bottom. Click on next. Bring him back.
And then we can click on start crawl.
And then it will just go from page to
page adding in all of the data for us.
And just like that guys, we just sit
back. Where's our cup of coffee? Drink
our beautiful coffee and just let
instant data scraper do what it does
best. And I've just stopped this one as
for instance. But guys, look at the
level of this. This is crazy. And then
what we can do with this guys is just
download the CSV, run it through AI,
extract the emails, put into tables, and
do a bazillion different things. And
just like that, you've got a lift of
their followers, basically all their
information, um, their Instagram URL. So
again, now we can start reaching out to
them. We could do a bazillion different
things. And now we've covered that
beautifully free lead scraping tool. I
want you to think back to the California
Gold Rush in the 1900s. We talked about
the ones who could find the leads and
how they made a lot of money. But the
people who made the most amount of money
were actually the people who were
selling the gold diggers the shovel. And
I want you to ask yourself this one
question. of all the agencies that you
know the AI agencies or even businesses
for example in the space who has the
most amount of leads and what is the one
thing that they all have in common if
you think about it deeply for a second
it's that they all own media and I told
you early in this this master class that
people start off scraping leads in
manual outreach is how I got my first
business off the ground I just Instagram
DM people hey I have this really cool
solution to this problem you have but
the way that people get leads
inconsistently and this is something
that no one's telling you and I'm going
to tell you the truth
is it's media you are creating digital
assets that actually and that is one of
the best lead generation tools that you
can do and to some extent people have
been sold this lie and I'm going to tell
you the truth you want to create content
we have a very very specific window
where you can build a personal brand and
leverage it and I'm going to show you
now three different ways that you can a
few different strategies you can apply
to crush this and I want you to bear in
mind it's to do as I do not what I today
like think about that a little bit. Like
if you think of the top performers like
they can tell you to you need to do XYZ.
Are they doing it or are they creating
medium? Are they creating content that
attracts businesses that solve that
problem? Do you see what I'm saying? And
so the these systems I'm going to show
you have generated multi7 figures for me
for businesses and that's what I'm going
to show you because they are super duper
effective. And we're going to begin with
Instagram. Now these are ones that you
can use in many different ways but we've
got Goku here having a rock and time.
So, what is a growth system that you can
use on Instagram? And these are going to
get more powerful as they go on, which
is I just think that's a cool way to
structure this. So, this is what we do.
The first thing we do with Instagram is
we find the content that's working. And
by the way, this is a strategy help me
to get to almost 40,000 subscribers in a
matter of months and get around 300
emails a day just by doing exactly and
I'm not I wasn't an Instagram expert. I
just did this process. So, you can just
copy them. We find out what's working.
Okay, this is format, topics, and
engagement. So, if you're talking about
beautiful purple bottles, if you're
talking about financial advisors,
plumbing, architecture, you name it,
whatever the thing is, we find the
accounts that are crushing it. We look
at the topics, we're looking for things
that highly engaged, and we find the
formats. Once we've done that on a big
list, we then build the scraper that I'm
going to show you. Um, and then we store
the viral outliers into a sheet, which
basically means every single week you
get a full download break list of the
viral outliers. And then what we do is
capture emails in ManyHat. And so what
ManyHat will do is send them a message,
and I'll show you this in the system in
a second to say, "Hey, do you want this
free lead magnet, the free resource?" If
so, you grab the email, you're ready to
rock and roll, and then we nourish them
to growth, which is cool. So once you've
done that, you can start to win. So let
me show you exactly how this works in
practice. Now, if you're just starting
off on Instagram, this isn't an
Instagram master class, but I just want
to give you the detail of how you can
actually generate leads from Instagram
is you need to warm the accounts up
first. This is something that I found. I
wasn't sure if I was shadowbanned, but
basically you follow lots of similar
accounts, you engage with them for a
period of like two or so weeks, then you
need to post consistently every single
day about the thing. If the more work
you do in deconstruction in finding the
formats and styles that work well, the
better you will do. Now, effectively the
way this works is you're going to and
remember everything is about hooks. For
example, one of the things that we built
in our accelerator, you'll find this
really interesting is the you don't need
to reinvent what works with. So, if I
show you this thing on hooks, for
example, if I say, "Hey, I'm doing a
video on, I don't know, uh, a scraping
tool that makes getting leads very
easy." What this will do is scrape like
a massive viral database of hooks, um,
that have already been pre-validated and
it will do is give you three different
ideas with specifics of that video
working and then actually enable you to
create hooks yourself. And so, anytime I
create short from content, now I do
this. You can get a library of like
loads of viral hooks and you basically
just do stuff like this. So, for
example, hey, if you're insert need to
if you're a sales pro struggling to find
quality leads, you want to get automated
pipeline, let's go with three-step plan.
Everyone tells you finding leads online.
No one shows you how to do it. Here's a
30 secondond step-by-step tutorial on
how you can scrape this. If you want to
end up wasting hours on cold call
outreach, then skip this video. So, just
pick one and you run with it. So,
remember hooks are pretty much
everything with this stuff. Now, what
we're going to do is we want to get a
list of all the beautiful counts. And
again, I'll put this down below for in
description so you can just have this
Instagram operating system here. We grab
it. Basically, we just keep on scraping
it again and again from Appify. And then
we get the transcript and we just add it
into this beautiful air table. And then
when you come for ideas, you can go
through to find out what are the
outliers, what all the ones that have
done really well, like 73,000 views,
lots of comments. And you'll notice it's
all about type the word XYZ down below
and I'll send you over the video. So the
concept of this is that we create a mini
lead magnet. The way that I personally
do it is I'll do a huge video. Okay? So,
for example, this video here I did on
rag um 14,000 views. I spent like a week
building this. I put a lot of time into
it and it's a really it's really good
video. But what that means is I can then
repurpose that content and use it across
different platforms and I have like lead
magnets I can use. So the formula is you
basically create short content, you
optimize the hook, you find out what
works, and then you say, "Hey, if you by
if you want this full thing, just type
the word X down below." Once we've done
that, we then head over to Many Chat.
And as you can see, some of these guys
have thousands of runs. Um, it really is
crazy. They just harvest emails. You
come down. You're going to click on
automation. You can duplicate or click a
new one if you want to, but I'm just
going to duplicate this for argument
sake. Um, we come up this one. We click
on this guy. And then basically guys,
what you do on the left hand side, click
on edit. Now on a specific post or real,
you just click on next post or real. So
basically the next thing you post, this
will work for. Okay. Then you say reply
to the comments under the post. So this
is just when they type the word like
scraper or your keyword, this will then
reply to that with that. So say, "Hey,
might be like, "Hey, just DM'd you.
Just DM'd you." Bam. Cool. Sweet. And
then you've got the message they get.
And you can see how this all works on
the right hand side. Then send me the
link. And the only thing that you're
looking to do, guys, you can add this
thing in here, which is ask them to
follow you before they get the link if
you want to cuz Instagram is kind of
like the cloud platform basically. And
then what we do is on the link here, we
just replace this with your lead magnet
and then it just sits there. So I want
you to get into the concept of creating
content. You need to be creating
content. Okay? It's like crucial to
create content if you want to win on
easy mode. It's creating content. You've
just got to get started. Now look, we
basically enter lead magnet there and
then we just update and once that goes
live pretty much whenever anybody
comments, they'll then get a lead
magnet. Now once we get that, we then
begin the um lead nurturing thing. And
actually this exact same process I've
done to scale to tens of th almost
40,000 followers on Instagram. Now I did
this because what happens is when people
comment on your Instagram, it boosts up
in the algorithm. It gets this kind of
self-reporting cycle and you basically
crush them. Number five is the beautiful
LinkedIn. Now a key thing to understand
about LinkedIn is that it has the
highest net worth per individual user on
the platform. And there's a reason that
you need to understand why LinkedIn is
so important to use now in 2025. Think
about it like this. Less than 1% of the
entire platform posts weekly. That like
I'm not joking at those sorts of
numbers. It is crazy. I want to say guys
do not sleep on LinkedIn. Like I
recently started building my LinkedIn. I
I got one here guys with 1,49
comments. I told you that rag video I
can now repurpose that into multiple
different assets. Now think about this.
That's 1,400 people that I can now have
a conversation with. Say, "Hey, James,
saw that you really saw you interested
in rag video. By the way, do you know
anybody who needs help building these
systems and now I have thousands of
people that I can have a conversation
with and you can post this stuff
regularly. Like it is a hugely
underutilized platform. Think about
this. Most people on LinkedIn work for a
company and they can't really post
regularly because they're too concerned
about how is this going to look? What's
this going to look like?" So, you as an
entrepreneur have a superpower. So,
posting on LinkedIn absolutely crushes
it. Now, the way that it works on
LinkedIn, I'm going to come back to in a
second, but I just want to show you that
like um I'm not saying I have a million
follows on LinkedIn. I've applied this
stuff in my own personal business and
I'm seeing incredible results from it.
So, I'm just going to no cap give you
the stuff that's working for me. Now,
look at this. We have the platform here.
I want to give you five quick hacks. As
you can see, the numbers, the date, the
details, it is crazy how this stuff
blows up. Let's look at five. Number one
is you need to cross the valley of
cringe. Okay. So, what do I mean by
that? I mean that being cringe is what
separates you from your results. Now, I
spent years not creating a YouTube
channel cuz I was thinking about what
would people think um you know what my
friends think, my colleagues blah blah
blah blah in reality and it's crazy to
think that right now cuz that's it's
just second it feels like second nature
now. But that was an actual thought
process I had. Now most people will post
on LinkedIn, they'll get two replies,
two comments and they don't post again.
It is one of the highest numbering ever.
One of my friends that I met at the
school games got 0 to $50,000 in a
month, which is not typical, by the way.
I want to be clear that is not typical.
But he did it um obviously had a lot of
work done before that by LinkedIn. He'd
create posts, he'd have engagements,
he'd sell them in DMs. Really, really,
really, really freaking cool. Number
two, the first thing we do when you want
me LinkedIn account um is find 20
similar accounts. So, for example, I
would go in if I would search a
automations and I just find the best
accounts in AI automations that are
crushing it right now. Then I'd find out
what resonates. So, like what are the
content types, the formats, the styles
that are crushing it. Little tip, by the
way, is go beyond your niche. Cuz if all
you do is look at stuff within your
niche, you lose the ability to think
originally and critically, which is what
I I I like to do. I pride myself on
that. And so, you just become a
derivative content creator, which is not
what you want. But you want to find find
workspace to find resonates. And then
what you want to do when you're getting
off because on LinkedIn it's hard to get
initial traction I found because when
you're first posting you get like one
like two like and there's no momentum.
You want to get past a point where
you're getting like 10ish likes per
comment per post and or at least two or
three comments. It's more the comments
that we care about. Once you reach that
if you're posting good quality stuff you
haven't had the ability to start going
up and going into Stella. And so we do
every day we basically get 20 tabs
planet and we get on every one of their
profiles and we just drop value. Why
that's so important is because your ICP,
the person you're trying to target is
already following those accounts. So
you're showing up daily in that comment
section. You're getting visibility,
you're seen, people will then come start
to follow you and engage with you and
have meaningful conversation. This takes
an hour a day maximum to create the
content and engage with people. If you
can't sacrifice an hour a day to grow
your LinkedIn profile, then you got to
ask your question, do you really want
the results that you can get from
LinkedIn? cuz the sponsorship people get
on LinkedIn, the deal flow, everything
is insanity. So, it's really worth your
time. And then we copy what it works.
So, what why have I got Zinga Poker on
there? The CEO of Zinga Poker had a very
honest reflection recently. And I'm
going to show you the funnel that we do
on LinkedIn in a second that's crushing
it that you probably have never seen
before. Zinga Poker basically said, the
CEO, you do not know enough to create
something new. Like, you have no right
to correct something new. I was like,
"What does that mean?" Zinga Poker, when
they launched, they basically found the
best performing poker websites out there
and they copied everything on this
website, okay, down to the color of the
felt on the board because it works. And
he said once you copy what works and
it's functional, you then, okay, do it
better. So the way they made it better
was they made it you didn't have to
download Zinger Poker to use it. Okay.
and just turns out that just by that
process, you lose 50% of your signups
and then literally just by not even
being original, they grew up. But I'm
not saying you become never copy
somebody, but what you want to do is
understand what works. Like your time is
precious. You don't need to spend all
your time trying to create new hooks cuz
people have already validated the hooks
that work. Okay? We find the content
formats that work and the topics that
people care about, right? That's that's
kind of the game. And then you do it you
deliver in your own style, your own
unique thing. Now, what is the funnel?
How do we turn viewers into buyers?
Well, the way that it really works on
LinkedIn is it's the same concept as
Instagram I found where you basically
say comment X down below to get the
thing and then you send it to them. But
what the top creators on the platform
are doing is basically getting emails.
And there was a really interesting uh
content creator who attributes over a
third of his sales to this one strategy.
And I did the exact same thing. I'm
going to show you what that is. And it's
called an AI micromagnet. Now, the way
that this works is I'm going to sign in
real quick. So we load up chat GPT. We
come on the left hand side for GPTs
which is over here I believe in explore.
Okay. Now you're looking for my GPTs in
Chrome. So here's the concept of this.
Okay. And I'm going to pull up a
beautiful diagram to show you this. So
the way the micromagnet strategy works
is most people you'll have a lead
magnet. Okay. You give them value to a
problem and you say if you want the
resource to this type a word down below.
Most people they get the word they send
in the resource. What we can do instead,
and I've had hundreds of people do this,
we basically instead of doing that, we
create a custom GPT. Okay? So, for
example, I did a custom GPT as you can
see here on do you remember the
exploding box where you would um you
know basically give a prompt and this
had hundreds of people use it. Okay? So,
for example, instead of just giving you
the prompt, I put it in GPT where you
needed to have a conversation with it
where you'd open it up. It's like, what
kind of room should you explode?
whatever it is, you give it the
information and then it gives you the
resource in the chat. Now, what's really
cool here, if I go down here on the
GPTs, when you create it, you can
actually give it loads of resources.
Now, what happens is what you say with
this micro magma is once it's given the
thing, you okay, let's say that we're
teaching people how to make faceless
shorts, right? And we say, here's the
prompt to get this really cool reliable
result every single time. Well, you
know, banana prompt. Awesome. By the
way, Jack, here's a full video, a 2-hour
master class showing you exactly step by
step how to take this to the next level.
And so, what we have now is the GPT
selling them on the thing. So, they get
the resource, they get the custom GPT
with your knowledge, based information.
And the GPT says, "Awesome, next step is
to then if you want this to be
consistent or if you want to get five
different versions of this, you can
watch this video here." And then the GPT
points them towards your master resource
and then that gets to nurturing and then
you convert them and that's basically
how they crush it. So, another one is um
think lead magnets, right? Or hooks. So,
Chris Donley did this, who's very big on
LinkedIn, which is I spent four years
building hooks. I put them on custom
GPT. Check it out down below. They get
the hooks. It's all going to point them
then to a resource, a GPT, and the GPT
is going to say, "Cool, you got the
hooks." But hooks without the body or
nothing. Here's a full video breaking
down how to get the body. Then they're
in your content ecosystem. So, you get a
nurturing pipeline. And that's one of
the most sickest lead generation things
you can do to absolutely crush it on
LinkedIn. And if you thought LinkedIn
was interesting, that is nothing
compared to YouTube, the platform on
which you're watching it right now. If
you want proof of this, you're watching
it right now. So hopefully that makes
sense. So YouTube, I've made over a
million dollars specifically from
YouTube and other platforms. And I've
actually spent over $25,000
on experts. These are consultants that
came into my team to help with YouTube.
Um, onetoone support, really invested in
my knowledge. Um, like this guy, you
probably seen him on YouTube. Very, very
cool, very knowledgeable. I did all this
so that you don't have to. Even had a
onetoone specifically on my YouTube with
the goat on Mercy. Now I'm going to show
you my top gens from every million
dollars earned a tilt from spending
$25,000 and Lux Factual stuff. And this
YouTube segment here is just a very
small truncated version of the full
breakdown I did inside my community for
my beautiful annual members. But I want
to touch on some of the highlights here
because I think it's really important.
But first I need to ask you a question
and it is how many weeks how many hours
in fact do you spend on content creation
and I want you to split them across four
categories idea packaging scripting
editing posting. Um because YouTube you
get out of it what you put into it. Now
this is what most people think is
important when it comes to YouTube. They
think a lot of it is about the editing
and the delivery. In reality 80% of
YouTube is the idea, the packaging and
the intro. In fact, the most amount of
time that I spent on this video was
actually the introduction because that's
the most important thing to really
understand the psychology of it. I'm not
going to get into too much depth in
YouTube, but I want to give you 80% of
what crushes on YouTube so that you can
apply that to your content funnel and
what the uh system looks like. Now, as I
say, 80% is idea and packaging. And if
you have a bad idea, you're going to get
low interest. Like, it doesn't matter
how good the editing is, the whisbang,
but if my video is about this purple
bottle, it's just not that interesting.
It's it's got to be something that's
really really interesting for people.
Poor packaging will give you low clicks.
But the question is where do you find
good ideas? How do you know what kind of
content to create on YouTube to get
leads? We find outliers. And one of the
reasons I'm showing this about YouTube
cuz a lot of people get leads for their
agencies from YouTube. So we find out um
you basically go on to platform like one
of 10. And what this will do is say,
hey, well based on your niche, these
other ones are performing uh really
well. So, for example, what this is
saying here is, did you know that this
video here, how to become so productive
it feels illegal? This is doing 20.3x
times better than his average viewed
video. So, for example, normally this
guy's getting 1.5k views. But for some
reason, this has now gotten 31,000 views
and is doing 20 times better. What that
tells us is this creator has created
content for something that hasn't had a
met demand yet. Like, the audience wants
something that they're not getting.
That's why it's so so popular. So what
we do is we prevalidate our ideas of of
this. And sometimes you say countries,
but again this is just finding out
what's worked. Like this video here for
example, this guy's really cool. I met
him in me.com conference. If you happen
to watch this video, hey bro, really
cool to see you. Um this is a 56.1x
outlier. Okay, 56 times better channel
average. So we find these outliers. Um
and you can do different things like
multiplier views, video duration, but
TLDDR of it is you want to be at least
2x multiplier. But the thing is, if we
look at this one, for instance, okay,
the views, you want at least 10,000
views. Cuz for example, if I check out
this guy, 2.7x outlier, but it's got
1,000 views. It's like, it could just be
the case that this guy did a good intro
this video. Like, there's that's not
enough validation of demand. At least
10,000 views is what we want. So, you
can look at this. You basically
deconstruct what do all the top
performing videos on this topic have in
common. you'd say, "Hey, well, the word
insane is everywhere, which if you're in
AI space, you know, the insanity uh that
I'm talking about here." All right. And
as you can see, if I look at all these
four things together, you can actually
analyze and break down what they all
have in common. So, for instance, here
um you it's actually kind of like ironic
you're watching this like an AI business
creator, but it's cool that we can chat
about this, right? Like they all have a
banana, you'll have a face in it, an
expression. They all promise you some
kind of results and it's big. It's
insane. It is incredible. Um it is
everywhere, right? And so you start
breaking down what the these four things
have in common and you end with the
quick checklist which is less 28 days,
10,000 views, 2x multiplier. Um then you
do competitive analysis. So for example,
you go through automation niche and find
what have in common, any general ideas
down every day and you spend hours on
those ideas. Then you got to understand
that what you make is more important
than how you make it and you have to
answer one question which is your
umbrella statement which is writing down
every problem that the avatar has. the
business you want to help and then you
organize them by most painful. So for
example, if you're targeting people who
want WhatsApp systems or they're not
getting good communications, we'd write
down all of the downstream effects of
that. And then you base your content on
solving one of those problems basically.
And you want it to be every video you
create needs to be either big, easy,
new, and safe. And ideally two of those
things and then you drive sales. Okay?
So to do that, you basically add value
by solving that problem. You do it
consistently even when you don't feel
like it. You get 1% better every week.
You have a product that solves the
problem that you're talking about and
then you include a link in YouTube and
that's it. That's basically it. And you
just have a link they can click down
below that solves the problem they talk
about. So for example, you know, for me,
one of the things that I talk about on
this channel, if you look at my
community, for example, we help people
get their first clients, learn AI with a
really cool, beautiful road map. And
we've become really good at doing that.
Um, which is why we got so many cool um
reviews and feedback on it. And so
that's basically the process with
YouTube. That's how you turn viewers
into buyers. you suck for a long period
of time, but creating content is
important. I want to express that it
isn't even just about driving clients
for for example my my consultancy Taii,
right? Because it isn't just about
getting people to come and buy, which
they do, and it's really cool. You know,
we give diagn diagnostics. This is like
the main the main focus of my business.
It's that it's a social lubricant. Okay?
So, when we book and help businesses
with Teddy AI, one of the interesting
things about it is that when they're
booking calls with you guys and you're
trying to get clients, one of the things
we'll often do is Google you and if
there's content on your YouTube channel
about you talking about the things like
let's say you're a lead generation guy
and I go your channel and there's, hey,
lead generation for businesses, here's
how you source lead gen, here's how you
do XYZ, you are way more credible and
it's like it actually will increase the
amount of conversions that you have.
You'll get more inbound lead flow if
there's a link they can click to come
down and book some time with you for
example. So if people want to chat with
me they can come and do that and get a
50-minute consultation with me to go or
my team basically to get a idea about
their diagnostics, the development, the
education others. This is basically as
simple as the funnel is. I create
content for businesses. They enjoy it.
They come down and then they book some
time with me and we talk about how we
can potentially help them and understand
what the problem is. And we can do that
because we've done it for so many
businesses. And that's the whole key
point. It's not just about lead flow.
It's about credibility that you have
these things backed up. YouTube is an
incredible platform. It is also the
trust platform. Okay? The more time you
spend with somebody, the more likely you
are to actually believe them and buy
from them. Now, number seven is
something very underrated that no one's
really looking at in terms of like
actually getting clients. And as a
system, what you want to do here is go
into communities. This could be school
communities like this one. In fact,
there are people in I cannot tell you
the number of people that have gotten
offers and deals and partnerships and
clients out of their ears just by being
in the community. I met a guy in London
on meetups. He said, "Dude, I'm working
with so and so. I just work with him
because I saw on the leaderboard in the
community and I wanted
insane." So, the idea with the community
site is you need to pick a community.
Could be a school, could be Facebook
groups, could be anything. And what you
do is you go into these communities and
you're just as valuable as possible.
Again, it could be LinkedIn groups,
Facebook groups, WhatsApp groups, school
communities, and you just add as much
value as possible to that community. You
get known as somebody who is a value
adder. And then who do you think they go
to the second they actually need help to
implement that thing? Like, it's
genuinely crazy. Like, online
communities are one of the biggest
exploding trends right now, but nobody's
jumping into it. And if you're not in
the community, you should really
consider it if you want to grow and
accelerate it. Not just because the fact
that you actually learn stuff, but
mainly because being in and around it,
it really helps keep you on track with
cracking down on your leads and just
lead flow and deal partnerships emerge
as a result of that. So, you want to
find niches on the internet that have
your ICP and with people trying to do a
similar thing because when you do that,
your lead flow will genuinely explode.
I've seen it so many times. It is
literally one of the most underutilized
hacks that exists. Number eight is a
profoundly powerful one and this is the
way that over 82% of people get their
first few clients. What is it? It's
their personal with a capital P network.
Now, why is that so important? The thing
is, you've got to think about this.
Let's say that you and your personal
network have 100 contacts. Okay? And
here we go. We've got 100 people right
here. Very few people ever actually say
to their network, "Hey people, I'm X. I
help Y avatar solve Z problem and get Z
you know Y benefit whatever the thing is
right if you know anybody any dentists
who want to you know get a 100 more
qualified leads per week from their
Instagram let me know now what's really
interesting is everyone in your network
if I was to ask for example five random
people this guy this guy this guy and
this guy call it four people okay what
do you do would they all tell me the
same thing or would they all give me
completely different results One key
thing you want to do is you want your
own personal network to have a very
clear understanding of the thing that
you do because that I'll tell you why
that's crucial. It's not just about
whether they would buy. It's their
network. So each one of the 100 people
that you know also take this guy for
example here. He knows 100 people. Okay?
And let's say for example that you
identified as I am the WhatsApp systems
guy. All right. And this guy, okay,
knows oh Jack. Oh, Jack builds WhatsApp
systems. If it's like Jack does
WhatsApp, he does bottles, he does this,
he does he'll do your SEO, your PPC,
it's like you're no, the cost of trying
to be good at everything is the cost of
being good at nothing. If I do
everything, no one can describe what I
do. There's somebody there's mult people
in my community and there's one guy who
literally is known for one thing and I'm
not joking. He gets leads weekly. It's
it's it's really impressive. Now, the
thing here is this. If I'm known as the
WhatsApp guy here, okay, Jack, I build
WhatsApp systems. You want anything
else? You want voice? You want this? I
can talk to you about it, but we just do
this one thing. I spent 25K on an agency
who did only one thing, which was SEO.
Now, I got my business's monthly unique
traffic to 50K per month, which is
really cool. You know, we had about
3,000 customers off that. It was very,
very cool. And I said, look, I've gotten
to the point where I know 80% of SEO.
what I want as an expert to take it from
that last 20% to scale us into like
multi6 figures and stuff. Um because my
it would just go to a point where it
just wasn't like the ROI of my time. And
one of the reasons I went with this
agency is because they said we don't do
paid ads. We don't do any of that stuff.
We're a boutique agency. We work with 10
clients maximum and we're just really
freaking good at SEO and it's 25K. And I
was like okay cool. That's pretty much
how the conversation went. So the point
is this. when they know that you do this
one thing which is WhatsApp systems. The
second that let's say for example
someone on the network and we'll call
this guy Dr. Orange says dude I need
some I need some WhatsApp systems. This
guy can say oh my gosh you need WhatsApp
systems you need to go over here to this
guy because I know it. But if he doesn't
know that about you there's no way he
can refer it. So the key here is that
your personal network is the fastest
route for you to getting your first few
clients. It just genuinely is. We need
to position your brand. Be clear on your
niche, but actually speaking to your
network and being clear on what it is
that you do, who you help solve what
problem. Remember, we talked about niche
is essential. And now you've got so many
leads you don't know what to do with
them. The next thing that we need to do
is turn those leads into dollar signs,
which you can learn by clicking the link
in the top of the description.